So today we're having a statewide training
for guide dog puppy raisers for
the entire state of Arizona.
We have five or six puppy raising
clubs in the state, and our Tucson club
which is called Paws for
the Cause is hosting this.
We do this about once a year, and
we have trainers for guide dogs come
and help us puppy raisers learn and fine
tune our skills for raising our puppies.
The University has been really
supportive in a lot of students in helping
to raise guide dog puppies, and my
professors are always really understanding.
Actually, Juan's been visiting our neuroscience
honors society club meetings and so all
of the members recognize him
and love him and welcome him
and they also really help in his socialization.
Well in addition to our statewide training
today, the puppy truck has come from Guide Dogs,
and this is a specially equipped van that
delivers puppies to new puppy raisers,
and also our recall, so dogs that have
been with our puppy raisers for the past 12
to 15 months are now going back to guide dogs
to start their formal training
to become a working guide.
It's kind of bittersweet, like
you know this day is coming,
you know they're not your dog forever, but it's
kind of bittersweet that I'm not going home
with the same dog I came with today.
I love working with the dogs, but I love
knowing that the dog I've raised is going to go
on to potentially change someone's life.
The first dog we raised was matched
with a young man that was 21 years old,
and after he got a guide, he was able to move
out of his parent's home and live independently.
So that's what makes it worthwhile
when you have to say goodbye.
[People chatting]